construyeron unos ductos subterráneos
que son en realidad Galerías
subterráneas Galerías filtrantes por
donde se filtra el agua de la superficie
y construyendo canales los llevaron por
gravedad hasta sacarlos a la superficie
[Música]
no estimamos que 29 acueductos están
todavía en funcionamiento no y gracias a
este sistema hidráulico pues no pueden
pueden ver como pueden ver todo el valle
está verde no Entonces es importante
también este la importancia que tiene
este sistema para la agricultura no
[Música]
más bien gracias a los antiguos
agricultores que han tenido esa esa
tecnología avanzada que ellos han
procreado aquí en el Perú y mucho nos
sirve para la Última Generación
[Música]